new figures released by the Bank of
England show that the amount lent out in
mortgage debt has hit its highest level
since 2008 raising fresh fears are the
new housing boom skies economics editor
ed Conway is here with me so what to
today's figures teller said well I can
show you this on our exciting new
touchscreen actually we had some new
figures out from the bank of england
which showed you just what is happening
to mortgage lending this just shows you
how much banks were lending out each
month over the course of the past few
years and look-- since 2008 since the
crisis you can see that this has been
more or less on about the same kind of
line until the last few months is the
last few months just look at what
happened shoots out it shot up very
sharply indeed so she's actually at the
moment in the past three months you've
had 6.8 billion pounds lent out families
for mortgages how much of a concern it
is that figure our people borrowing too
much to find that out you have to
examine just how many of these mortgages
are high debt mortgages and I can show
you that too i mean this this shows you
basically the scale the proportion of
mortgages which are over four and a half
times a family's income in other words
high debt mortgages and you can see this
pink line shows you london that's
basically the london housing market
getting very sloppy more than twenty
percent of people buying borders in
London are buying high debt mortgages
but the same goes for most of other
parts of the country as well and you can
see that's just kind of risen recently
but this is where the financial crisis
home this is the banking crisis people
couldn't borrow that's the banking
crisis but since the banking crisis
things have shot up in terms of just how
much people are buying high debt
mortgages so that has got worse look we
talked a lot and we're going to continue
talking a lot about the cost of living
crisis don't we mortgages are for most
of us the biggest expenditure that will
exact are they manageable yeah and
that's the question whether it can
people actually afford to kind of keep
up their monthly payments and I've got
each other just shows you that this is
basically how much of your monthly bill
is going into interest payments on your
bill and you can see basically on your
mortgage well you can see interest
payments back in the in the kind of late
80s Early 90s those interest payments
i'm going to show you actually rose
around this period they raised about
quarter of the average household
average bills now it came down a bit
after that so you have the big housing
crash in the early 90s there it came
down a bit and right now it's still
around that kind of ten to fifteen
percent level is kind of it's still
hanging around that level so a lot of
people would look at this and say Ashley
it's all right these mortgages are
pretty affordable for people yeah but
that's because presumably we've had low
interest rates for quite a sustained
period that's the killer kind of concern
is that just look at that period their
interest rates at this stage when
mortgage is worth just as kind of expect
expensive as they are now we're about
five percent whereas now then naught
point five percent so interest rates are
very low at the moment any expectation
is they're going to go up what happens
then well just I mean keep an eye so
basically those are that's where
interest rates are at the raven or point
five percent and almost every investor
these are just expectations these
colorful lines just show you expectation
from various different investors about
where rates are going to go up and you
can see at the end of twenty say we're
2014 at the moment coming up coming up
quite quite sharply there according to
different investors though great
decision on Thursday what should we be
looking out for their what the
expectation is that rates are going to
come up at some point and you can see
that kind of sharply but it's not going
to happen this week it may well happens
was the end of this year maybe early
next year at Conway thank you